obtenir le petit moment incroyable là-bas, nous y allons en
fait ouais ça a l'air mieux
o cabelo ouais
et je crois que vous avez fait ça pour votre
film dans quel décor personne ne tire comme
ça pour les débris afin que vous puissiez avoir un travail
ouais Merci Spencer Wow regarde c'est
en remontant cette colline à l'arrière ouais on
baise jusqu'à 700 si on se rapproche du stylo ou est-
ce que c'est vraiment un bon
carburant d'accord on peut essayer de le vérifier sur
le chemin on a comme 45 secondes ici
on est bon  En tant que Sylvia, je peux absolument
passer facilement mr.  Lester un prix final
tu es basica parce que dans leur
cours numérique officiel LOL à je vais
devoir y aller ou quoi
que ce soit parce que je le souhaite, je veux dire un décent je peux tout ce
que je ne veux pas une seconde mignonne de ça
l'avion est sur le point d'être toi pour elle jusqu'à présent
ouais
ils finissent en zoomant simplement sur les
flammes ouais oh ouais on attend juste un
peu parce que tu sais ce que
ces flammes étaient vraiment grosses 35 ou 40 d'
accord alors comme à 37 tu peux faire  mieux vaut être d'
accord
et ensuite nous ouvrirons parce que sinon vous
n'obtiendrez pas que les gens décrivent ces
haut-parleurs propriétaire de riches
ça pourrait aller
chocho serosa ah [ __ ] c'est raccroché nous le
faisons je suis tout le chemin et je
juste à la fin d'accord, je n'arrêtais pas de
penser qu'il y avait plus de place oh je
veux dire qu'il n'y a pas grand-chose que vous puissiez faire avec
ça ouais je pense que vous avez quelques
minutes d'accord pour localiser pour
réellement tenir un emplacement d'éducateur juste
pour un  quelques minutes les
gens ils le méritaient il ne va pas
trop loin
on dirait foothill ranc  h contre une
atmosphère alors oui silverado canyon un
de ces canons au-dessus du lit
là-haut viens sur mon neveu RX bizarre
il y a une sorte de chouette d'avoir des villes et des
gens ici pour évaluer les
transmissions obtenues commercialisables sur la côte nord des palmiers
où je tire à plus  à Roger, je
pense que nous pouvons encore obtenir la ville, je vais
juste pouvoir l'élargir maintenant, ça
nous regarde l'atmosphère ouais merci
regarde regarde un peu mieux mais en fait
tu vois il y a comme quatre endroits là
au milieu comme c'est comme si je  besoin d'une
assiette dommage que le feu ou la liste
soit qu'ils étaient ils étaient là-dedans dans le
SPO là-bas ils vont devoir allumer
maintenant
bon hé mec ils disent ce
pyromane en série avec une cible des
familles heureuses bien que ce n'était '  t tout brûle
leurs maisons, ils seraient plus heureux
c'est terrible personne horrible
ils ont l'air heureux Je ne suis pas content c'est
juste un fardeau à porter que la
jetée de Santa Monica oh non oh j'offrirai
toujours cette façon à l'intérieur des terres il y a un vieux et
façon dont je sorte oh tu as vu l'ours
Swilly
et si tu aimes zoomer pour le construire lentement sur
ce feu je ne sais probablement
pas je ne ferai probablement rien j'ai choisi je vais faire un
bon
ouais c'est en quelque sorte le premier je ne peux pas y aller
mieux